[Applause]
[Music]
definitely not the same harry styles
continues to change the music game with
his latest offering as it was
[Music]
it's the lead single off his highly
anticipated third studio album harry's
house and the lyrics have fans thinking
harry must have love on the brain
harry broke down the meaning of the
track on siriusxm's the morning mashup
on friday revealing the inspiration
behind his new music comes from the joy
he's experiencing in his life right now
i also feel really happy at the moment
and and
i feel like
it's the first time i feel like i'm kind
of making music and putting music out
from from a real place of kind of
personal freedom
[Music]
it's not hard to put the pieces together
harry's happiness probably has something
to do with his girlfriend olivia wilde
this is my dream come true devoted fans
are catching this easter egg in the
lyrics
you know who's got two kids you guessed
it olivia that's right that is right
naturally stans are losing it given that
this just might be the first time the
singer's referenced his relationship
with the actress the romance between the
two first made headlines in early 2021
when they were first spotted holding
hands during production of olivia's
upcoming movie don't worry darling which
harry starrs in i feel very grateful to
have been able to
explore acting and a source recently
told et that the pair is going strong
and couldn't be happier they are pretty
low-key and really just love spending
time together along with their families
and friends it's nice to try and keep
that bit of the private because it's
yours our source adds that their
families have blended so seamlessly and
harry's mother adores olivia and her
kids and speaking of kids did anyone
catch this moment at the start of the
song come on harry we want to say
goodnight to you now some think this
might be the voice of one of olivia's
children but not so fast harry confirms
the voice comes from someone else very
special to him it's the voice of my god
daughter she used to try and call me
before bedtime every night so
one time
i don't know it didn't ring or something
she sent me that and and i kind of dug
it out
at some point while we're in the studio
and and
put it in front of the song for some
reason and
i kind of just fell in love with it so
it stuck well there you have it as for
the identity of that youngster it's
producer ben winston's five-year-old
daughter ruby yeah that's ruby that's
ruby she's his
goddaughter the singer developed a
close-knit bond with ben when the two
worked together during harry's one
direction days harry he's
amazing as it was it's just the first
taste of what harry's got cooking for
harry's house the full album comes out
may 20th so until then we'll be
listening to as it was on repeat
as it was
[Music]
you